what is a personal brand a personal
brand is what people say about you when
you're not around that's what your
personal brand is it's what you're known
for so when you're not at that
conference or that dinner party or that
coffee meeting um and your name pops up
in the conversation what are people
saying about you that's your personal
brand it's what you're known for
ultimately I'm very much on your page
here in terms of sort of I've drunk I've
been drinking this this kind of Kool-Aid
and living this world for for a for
quite a long time y but often I'll find
uh when I throw out the word personal
brand people will kind of like the word
sales people have a bit of a a cringe
response to that what's what's going on
there I I think it's because I think
personal branding as a whole I mean look
it's not a New Concept personal brands
have been around for decades and decades
right um but I think it's still a little
unknown it's it's a little unknown it's
a little unsure in terms of what it is
and how it works and I feel I also feel
like
because a lot of people don't know
people who have personal brand
businesses um it's kind of like a weird
sort of ice it's almost like an iceberg
right like see an iceberg floating
around somewhere in the Arctic you can
see what's above the water but you can't
see what's underneath it so you see the
influence that the personal brand is
having you see potentially maybe the
money that that personal brand
entrepreneur is making but you don't see
what's underneath right and icebergs
what are they like 10 times bigger
underneath than they are on top of the
water or whatever so that's that's a
whole bunch more there that's that's
opinions that's relationships that's um
you know the the things that make them
tick the things that they hate uh the
things they want to stay away from their
experiences the people that they want to
do more business with all that stuff is
all underneath yeah and that's unknown
that's unknown whereas the stuff on top
is known very clearly cuz it's it's
forward facing it's the front cover of a
book or it's who the person is on stage
or on a camera you know on on YouTube or
on Twitter or insta or whatever it is
and so I think a lot of people see
personal brand entrepreneurs as somewhat
vain because they they're putting
themselves out into the world and you
see a lot of these influencers so you
know hi everyone welcome back to my
channel you know today I'm that's
me yeah but then it's usually followed
up you know some of the some of the
things I've seen you know you know today
I'm going be clean in my kitchen why
don't you follow along hey you know what
if you want to watch somebody clean
clean the kitchen fair play go ahead and
watch them you know they built that
personal brand they're you know somebody
who focuses on looking after a busy home
or something like that and there are
people out there that are going to want
to watch that sort of type of content
because they want to speed up the house
clean every week or they want to become
a more productive mom or dad or parent
or whatever and so I think that a lot of
people look at the personal brand
entrepreneur and the element of personal
branding with a bit of a frown almost
because they don't know how it works
they don't know what's involved in
building a business-based around a
personal brand as well what's the
difference between a personal brand and
a I guess professional reputation or is
it is it the same thing just kind of in
different kind of words I think it is
yeah it is it's just a different way of
you know it's a different way of being
able to say this is what I do yeah
ultimately yeah cuz I guess when I
talked to my mom about this she wouldn't
understand the word personal brand but
if I if I said hey you know that famous
surgeon that you know he's got a
professional reputation right she's like
yeah of course that's a personal brand
yeah haha gotcha you know that kind of
thing yeah and I think maybe in some in
some in Industries some instances you
would use one and you would never use
another like for example a doctor yeah a
doctor wouldn't say I've got a personal
brand I wouldn't say a doctor unless
it's like Dr M or some other American
right Dr pH or something like that yeah
yeah yeah um and I mean you know Dr Phil
is the perfect example of a personal
brand as well he's got his own show he's
got his books he's got his you know he
does what he does you know Oprah one of
the biggest personal Brands the planets
ever seen and probably likely will ever
see she's got an incredible story behind
her she's spoken and interviewed some of
the most influential important highly
respected individuals that the world has
ever seen and therefore you've got that
Association of what you know there like
everybody knows who opah Winfrey is
everyone you stop anybody in the street
show a photo of her you're don't even to
say her name oh that's Oprah that's a
personal brand it's what you're known
for hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye-bye